today we are going to be speaking to
another 2022 candidate and we will be
speaking with Republican Allison Hayden
Allison Hayden is running for congress
in California's 14th District against
Eric swalwell the current Democratic
congressman from California's 15th
congressional district now running in
the 14th due to redistricting Allison
it's great to have you on I really
appreciate your time
good morning hi so indulge me if if you
will because there are such diverse
views about this among Republican
candidates running I've been starting
with what may be a simple question and
if it is that's great and we can move on
who is currently the president of the
United States
Joe Biden okay and do you believe that
his presidency reflects the will of the
people as they voted in 2020.
uh I doubt it I I don't know I don't
know you don't know where you doubt it
uh I would say with so much controversy
around election Integrity which is
actually my first
um
I think mandate when I get in is really
to clean up our election processes that
there are two there are too many
questions it's really not for me to I'm
not on the inside of that so well you
did retweet a meme that says Trump won
so it seems something made you believe
that that you do know who actually won
right so you you tweeted a meme that
says Trump won what makes you think
Trump won well you know I live in
Northern California and so many people
even Democrats
told me they voted Trump so the numbers
didn't seem to reflect my experience
and so so because some Democrats told
you this is my you know yeah in my own
interactions with people I mean Trump
did get six million votes so certainly
you could have been talking to some of
those six million that's not really
evidence of fraud is it
no I'm not I I will say I went in and I
was an observer in the processing of
votes okay and there were big problems
with that like what and I even called
out uh I I witnessed uh
a vote being called for Newsom
that I could clearly see was not Newsom
on the ballot
okay but in terms of you tweet you
tweeted that Trump won you tweeted that
Trump won
what do you have to believe that okay
election Integrity yeah so I I think
there are questions with the vote okay
and we need for for everyone
you know that's That's the basis of our
constitution is the sovereignty of the
people Fair absolutely that should be
the first and foremost
um
you know
concern on every American
heart that that be assured I'm with you
100 I'm with you 100 now when I see the
numbers and I say you know there are so
many more Democrats in California than
Republicans that we know from voter
registration and Joe Biden won
California by five million votes
you tweeted that Trump won but it's
because a few Democrats you spoke to
said they voted for Trump that that
sounds weak a little bit doesn't it
Allison no well you know what when you
have a vote that is uh perhaps
um compromised so are the registrations
actually anything electronic we we need
to run through all the voter rolls
because there are you know we don't
really know what's real so so you think
even the voter registration is the
veracity of what is being touted as uh
you know representative of Republicans
Or democrats but let me just say from
the outset David that I am not a waving
a party banner I think that Americans
are hurting this is not the election
or the time in America to be caring
about political party membership I think
that I rejected the Republican Party
endorsement
I want to
represent Republican values that made
this country strong and those that's
what I care about so I want to clean up
the vote and voter rolls because that's
that is you know the voice of the people
is what represents this country's
freedoms and you know we have to get to
the bottom of that we do but I guess the
issue I'm having Allison and this is why
I'm so interested in talking to you is
if you want to be taken seriously on
that it seems as though some of the
things you're repeating on your Twitter
don't really make it so that someone
would take you seriously I'll give you
another example yesterday you retweeted
a meme indicating that 25
000 dead people voted in Michigan that's
been looked at the that that's just not
true why why would you retweet that if
you're so serious about this you know
Twitter for me is as much about raising
awareness and about uh people really
rethinking all of these things because
you know again I saw that
um actually today I just saw that the
Secretary of State Benson yeah had voted
to keep 26
000 dead people on on the voter roll so
we have problems okay that's long and
short of it and Twitter I use
as education and to bring awareness and
to bring discussion we need to have
discourse about it and it ferrets out
more information you know when you throw
things into the Public Square I this
whole notion of discourse this is what
is lost in America and this is what made
us strong iron Allison I'm sorry I hate
to interrupt but you're going so off
track do you how many dead people do you
believe voted in Michigan
you know I again I'm not on the inside I
could not speak to that question so how
did you why were you comfortable
retweeting something for us to all look
at the voter rolls uh I don't know if
you've seen any of Dr Douglas Franks
interview uh his actually he's been
going around the country showing us what
he discovered and he's done just on
Public Information
um watching and he has the voter rolls
for the last 20 years he's potentially
criminally in possession of voting
machines and is being investigated by
the FBI I don't know that that Douglas
Frank is the person I would look to on
this but in the end I'm not sure the FBI
is where I would look to for for
confidence either oh yeah are you a
supporter of law enforcement you know I
am definitely but you know what we have
I think what's been exposed in America
yeah is it's underbelly and we have many
problems across many institutions and
this is the hour to clean up America not
to shore up anything that has has uh
Fallen you know when you have humans
leading institutions you can expect that
there's going to you know eventually
things get corrupted and we have seen
how many of these institutions that we
have counted on relied on have have
problems and as much as the voter rolls
same with the intelligence agencies we
need to end law enforcement I live in
Alameda there are there is by the
Sheriff's Office itself admitting how
corrupt things have become so you know
instead of trying to defend something
let's all come together unite to fix it
the problem is Allison this is for the
American people this is not about Party
politics it's very wishy-washy to insist
on coming together to fix things without
being able to demonstrate that they need
fixing and I'll give you an example
there is no evidence whatsoever that
anyone other than Joe Biden easily won
in California there is no evidence at
all that the voter rolls in California
are off there is no evidence that dead
people voted in Michigan there is no
evidence that the FBI investigation of
Mike pillow and Frank that you mentioned
is anything other than a completely
legal and well-established investigation
it's very easy to just say let's just
come together and we let's just let's
just fix it but when you're wanting to
fix things without being able able to
provide proof that they're broken it
doesn't feel like it's a good faith
position
when people are in control of what is
said to be true or not and they
themselves are the corrupt ones we don't
know
so your claims
coming from them from from people in
positions who themselves may be the ones
but they're not making claims well
you're saying I'm saying you're you're
making the claim you're making the claim
and showing no evidence about I'm sorry
you're making the claims extraordinary
claims and providing no evidence America
is shouting for truth in voting okay the
confidence of the American voter is
completely eroded
and we need to fix it we need to shore
up everyone's confidence and that's
Democrats Republic every every political
stripe Americans are Americans and we
stand here and our borders are impacted
because the world wants to come here and
live and to have the freedoms that we
possess all right and it is our duty As
Americans to make sure those freedoms
are are stand strong and we
we need to do that and not trying to
defend something we need to win if
there's no problem what's the problem
that's that's my question to you listen
let me let me ask you something else
Allison because I know you know we want
to focus on evidence you tweeted that
antifa rioters were actually the ones
breaking into the capital on January 6th
and that Maga Patriots were trying to
pull them away from going into the
building you don't honestly believe that
now do you I'm not sure I tweeted that
you did you tweeted it you tweeted it uh
January 8th 2021 we can provide the
citation
there were provocative well I mean
please send me that tweet I would love
to see it sure um I mean I tweet a lot
of things but I mean the things you
tweet
there were provocateurs there
and they were in the crowd
and they were you know Ray Epps was Oath
Keepers he's uh known to be an FBI
Associated person there is absolutely no
evidence that rayaps is an FBI
Associated person not the fervor the
night before and that has been
completely debunked Allison it's been
completely different Allison do you mean
the things you tweet
as I said I used tweets also to it to
get people to talk about subjects which
are not settled we need to clean up
America Allison do you believe that the
700 going on David would you not want it
sorted out I would not want those I was
brought to justice is there any evidence
whatsoever that you have that the 700
trumpist defendants from the capital
riots were not genuinely trumpists any
evidence
well do you have any evidence they
weren't yes their social media records
their social media histories the things
that law enforcement found in their
homes their Communications their uh
overt statements about their political
views we have we have all of that do you
have anything to suggest that none of
that is why people went when Washington
on January 6 because they questioned the
vote that's telling you that there are
many Americans who are not comfortable
with the way it went down but my
question was do you have any evidence
that they're not really trumpists
Allison hold on hold on a second you're
answering Quest different questions do I
told you why I believe they are
trumpists who went there no they dragged
out things you can put a different frame
on any evidence not a frame not a frame
hold on a second hold on a second
anybody can you can you can paint a
picture that is completely divorced from
reality by by cherry picking evidence so
is it cherry picking to say that the
rioters had exclusively pro-trump social
media history look a grandmother is
there in jail people that just cared and
they showed up and they dragged those
people before so this is not okay this
is not America those people have a right
to a First Amendment to to confront
their government when they have a
question but wait a second Allison hold
on a second wait a second Allison
Allison hold on a second Allison no you
first said hold on a second Allison wait
a second
nobody's gonna be able to hear you
unless we can each take a turn you first
said
you don't believe they were really Mega
Trump people and now you're saying hold
on let me finish the question not in my
mouth please Don't Feed things into my
mouth
everyone out there had I don't I can't
characterize I don't know them I have
never met those 700 people
I can't tell you what they were or were
not but they were out there made the
trip
because they were concerned about the
vote
so you agree that they were trumpists
that doesn't make you a trumpet that
makes you an American
concerned about the sovereignty of your
vote almost no Democrats were concerned
about the election I'm sorry that makes
you an American
wow Allison you know you sound disc
completely disconnected from reality
right like completely different ability
certainly your reality the empirical one
for which we have evidence no there's
nothing more empirical to yours than
mine really you have no right to to all
of a sudden stand on a high horse
there's no horse here no zebra no
nothing you know Allison when you ask me
what makes me believe something the
difference Allison is when you ask me
hold on a second but Allison wait a
second let's see if I can get a word in
edgewise Allison when you ask me why I
hold a certain belief
I give you the evidentiary reasons why
when I ask you why you hold a belief you
tell me Well we don't know or you answer
a different question you you never
provide any evidence do you see the
difference between my beliefs and yours
you're claiming evidence the evidence is
a is a p the people that showed up okay
that's evidence
that showed up and rioted because they
were mad
you know what people showed up at the
Capitol right because the president said
if you have questions you come out be an
American this was not to raid the
capital which they did though but they
did that
you know what there were infiltrators
there so the the rioters were not the
trumpists who were concerned about the
vote is that right I am not a person
that was is able to make any
determination about the people all I
know is that there were infiltrators
there that were whipping people up and
and trying to get things going wow so
Allison you're scaring me I'm scared for
the future of our nation really
genuinely and we should be that's what
that's what this is is all about yeah no
I mean if folks were to vote for you I
would be very scared we should have fear
about this this is why we need to get to
the bottom of it yeah
exactly the reason is to save America
this is not Trump or anything else all
right well you've heard it here from
Allison Hayden Trump it's not about
Trump it's about America your choices in
the 14th District and the rights
your choices in the 14th District are
Allison Hayden and Eric swalwell that
election will be just weeks away Allison
we're going to be watching that race
very closely
thank you thank you very much